Ô Beija Flor bate suas asas mais de 80
vezes por segundo aí Mostre beij já flor
em câmera
lenta como é que a pessoa sabe queem foi
a o filha da [__] que contou eu fico
pensando na falta do que fazer de uma
pessoa que conta os batimentos das asas
de um beijaflor fica imaginando o
diálogo de duas pessoas fal Meu amigo tu
sabia que esse beij flor bate as asas
mais de 80 vezes por segundo conversa é
essa meu irmão tô te falando meu amigo
tu tá ficando é doido como é que o cara
vai bater as asas 80 veem pro segundo
maluco o segundo ó um dois segundo já
como é que não tem como não meu amigo eu
tô falando você é estudado rapaz por
Bora contar bota em câmera lenta eu boto
Bora contar quer ver Câmera Lenta
vai olha aí
um dois o Beijo flor colhe o Néctar das
plantas e leva até os seus filhotes e a
Câmera já tá lá no nin dentro do n eu
fico pensando como o diabo esse cara
colocou essa câmera dentro do n do beij
flor